they are the allegations that ruined his
royal public life claims he's constantly
denied but now set out in black and
white in court documents filed in
america three occasions when virginia
defray alleges she was sexually abused
by prince andrew
he knows exactly what he's done and
i hope he comes clean about it
after speaking out for years she's used
the new york child victims act to push
for compensation and show the powerful
can be held to account
since
2015 these allegations have regularly
blown up for the royal family despite
those repeated denials from the duke of
york but what makes this different and
potentially more damaging is the fact
the lawsuit is the first we filed
specifically against prince andrew
again he faces demands for answers his
legal team have always insisted they
have cooperated with any requests but
this new case doesn't necessarily mean
he'll have to talk prince andrew is not
at peril of an extradition request
because a request for extradition can
only be made if he has been charged with
a criminal offence in the u.s an
application to dismiss the suit that's
been fired in the u.s could be made to
the u.s court i think we're a little way
off uh any requests for the the prince
to
give evidence or be deposed in such
proceedings
prince philip's funeral was a rare
moment in public with the rest of the
family for a man desperate to move past
the years of reputational damage this is
his horrendous albatross
you know gripping his neck it's hanging
around his neck like some evil totem
and sadly
this is a death by a million daggers
every time there's any distance from the
story another knife is put into the back
some people will say justifiably so the
long drawn out legal process only set to
keep it in the headlines whatever the
final outcome
rhiannon mills sky news at buckingham
palace